[Music]
um
what is that medical
[Music]
so
yes
[Music]
[Music]
rathalos
[Music]
now mila on the other hand when she
became involved in the movie she started
playing monster hunter world
and her favorite weaponry was the dual
blades
so we gave her the dual blades in the
movie
i love how they power up
what is that you gotta tell me about
that
and the ease with which you can use them
in the video game because i tried all
different manner of weapons to see what
i like best
and i felt like the dual blades they
were just an all-around great weapon
mila's swords she carries them on her
back like this
the first time mila walked into my
office she picked these things up and
she i i can't do it
i love sword work and so it really gave
me a chance to kind of do what i'm good
at doing
one of the great things about these
landscapes is they add reality to the
monsters
gave the animators who are doing the
creatures reality to lock into
there's real sun there's real wind so it
makes the monsters
look more real it was a real pleasure to
put them on screen
my favorite monster would have to be the
rathalos
you know he's just such a rock star and
he's so
badass and big and i love dragons
rathalos he's one of the toughest
creatures to kill he's a beautiful
creation he's
been in nearly all of the games but one
of my personal favorites is a creature
called the nacilla
which is kind of like a cross between
the alien
and a giant spider
a creature called the diablos she's
angry and
she lives underneath the sand and she's
one of the main adversaries
that our characters have to face in the
first half of the movie
and there's also the ramobra which is a
creature from some of the earlier games
it's like a
crossbringer hammerhead shark and a
snake
and also the paliko these are characters
from the games that are these
cat creatures that are super intelligent
and this palico is called meowskiller
chef
and he once was a warrior
and then at the very end of the film we
have the gormagala
which is a very rare creature from some
of the earlier games
and that's a kind of set up for a little
sequel potentially
hi i'm kerry vandalenfeldt i'm the pops
master on monster hunter it starts with
paul he gives his vision
and then we create it big my god
it's one of the features of the game as
they have these huge weapons which is
fine when you're a pixelated character
but when you have a human being that has
to handle these massive weapons
it's more of a challenge and i remember
showing tony his weapons for the first
time
i showed him the great sword and it's
taller than tony is
everybody picks up this sword and goes
oh
tony jar walked into my office he picked
it up and he went
he started doing the most amazing stuff
with he picked it up he starts twirling
it around and he went
they said that's great tony but you also
have to carry this
we gave him the great bow as well which
is even bigger than the sword
when we made them we give a copy to
stunts and once they're happy with it
then they bring the cast member in and
they show him what to do
and then obviously being tony job he
brings his interpretation to it
they train and they train and they train
so by the time they get to set
that's a well-oiled machine i got into
monster hunter 11 years ago
i played it in japan i fell in love with
the creatures the beautiful landscapes
the themes of the video game
so i optioned it from capcom my husband
optioned the property rights to this
game like 10 years ago
and he's been obsessed with this game
for the last decade
this has been the longest i've ever
worked on a film project and i'm kind of
glad that it took that long
because the game has evolved it's become
a worldwide phenomenon
monster hunter is a capcom game and
they've done a fantastic job in building
this franchise
it's been remarkable how much they've
allowed us to
take this project and adapt it in a way
that we think it could become a feature
abstract the fans of all these games are
very passionate about
the games and so when you stick your
head above the parapet and make a film
about the game you better get it right
there's not a lot of information
on the internet so we hired a consultant
who's a gamer who's
managed to finish this game he came in
and he would dress
avatars for us and then we managed to
compile quite a good wardrobe
that we could pull from we reference
things like you might not notice
straight away things like hieroglyphics
on the rocks for instance you know
the game is splattered with them and so
it's a subtle thing but it means a
massive thing to the fans
let's do this
let's go the people who made this movie
love monster hunter it was a crazy shoot
amazing locations this is an adventure
paul's very successful at taking games
and turning them into movies
it's lawrenceville radio with monsters
an epic genre movie
i was so excited when we saw stats
arcade straight out of the game one of
the great things about these landscapes
is it makes the monsters
look more real tony is like a real life
superhero
it's crazy miele brings a real inherent
toughness and
sense of honor to artemis
one of the features of the game is they
have these huge weapons i was always
a real fan of the dual blades
to see all of these characters come to
life it was a wonderful moment
[Music]
you